there's a really interesting idea of uh
bringing your emotion in line with your
thinking with your reasoning
so ben shapiro famously has this saying
how do you like that transition michael
you gave me props
i know you did he's not yeah
someone is not taking your calls benny i
guess it's the daily don't take the
caller
back to the island with the murder i
think we know
island we would know who would be
committing the murder
i have the suit for it uh so he has the
saying of uh
uh facts don't care about your feelings
and that always
um i i've always felt um badly about
that statement somehow like it was
incomplete
uh so it's interesting to uh that you
mentioned
bringing your emotions in line with your
thinking like what do you think about
that statement
is it i got this one what what ben is
doing
ben ben what he's doing in a a
loose way is attacking kantianism
because kant there's this it's it's
almost impossible for westerners who
aren't schooled in this
to understand the idea of philosophical
idealism because it sounds so crazy
that you're like these great minds of
all time can't really be saying this i
must be missing something
so the idea of when we hear idealism we
think john f kennedy right is
an example you you aspire things you
think life can be better than it is
that's not what it means in a
philosophical sense in philosophical
idealism it means
ideas are more real than reality
that i have this idea then this comes
along
it's the reality that isn't correct my
idea is still correct a good example
of this that you see all the time on the
internet is when they refer to mitt
romney
and john mccain as rhinos republicans in
name only
and it's like what is who is more a real
republican
the nominee of the party the senator
the governor of the party or some person
in your mind
who has never existed and there's no
evidence for them existing
so what kant did is he bifurcated
reality
into what we see around us the
phenomenal world
but then it's inferior the real world
the normal world we can't access it
because we have
eyes we only see the thing as it appears
not as it is
in itself and because of this everything
we know is a shadow
and is secondary that's plato yeah
that's straight out of place right and
the real reality is this realm of ideas
so when ben is saying facts don't care
about your feelings what he is
really saying is reality comes first
your feelings have to be a response or a
reaction to it
you can't say this is how i feel this
table doesn't care
you can yell at it all day long it will
still be indifferent to your emotional
state because it comes first
so it's it's a it's a great statement i
think he's cripping it for mine rand in
a sense and i
i love it i mean there's a sense in
which he is i mean who popularized that
kind of idea
and and ben is as red iron man quite
extensively not enough
not enough well not enough to reference
that's where the yarmulke so yeah
obviously um he may be ready enough but
didn't understand enough
um but so tired
it's absolutely reality reality is
unaffected by
your emotional state and your feelings
about it
and this is a great claim against the
idealism the philosophical idealism
of much of the world out there both left
and right i think politically culturally
the left and right are detached from
reality they live in a different
dimension in a different space that it
they are creating in their own minds
that has nothing to do with the real
world
and when they fail they make stuff up
to justify their failure right so this
is you know
all of really the the ideas that are
promulgated today
on both sides are this kind of detached
from reality
we're putting emotions or ideas before
before
reality itself but i believe that
you know emotions of responses the
responses to
reality conditioned by our
existing concept you're gonna have to
talk slowly to talk emotions to lex
because he doesn't really understand i
don't understand
so really you gotta really
i mean i could create we could create an
environment
on this island where you would really
feel emotions like fear is an emotion
that's the terror we could easily
terrorize you to the point
where you felt fear right so we can
teach him about emotions
but emotions are response to reason some
people for example you could you could
take
five different people and show them
exactly the same thing and some of them
would feel
fear and some of them would actually uh
you know feel indifferent and other
people might feel love
right uh i think leonard pickoff uses
the example of looking through a
microscope and seeing a
uh a a i don't know a virus or bacteria
and for one it's a scientist he's made a
new discovery he feels
pride and love and you know uh the one
is
has has no clue right and he's looking
at this and it means nothing to them and
somebody else might look at it
and you know it's a bacteria you know
and they feel fear because of what it
could do to them
so it's it's conditioned by what you
know what your values are
and your level of knowledge and what the
thing is out there in reality
and it's that into so your emotions
respond to that
um so
aligning your emotions with your reason
is making sure that
your emotions are really conditioned by
what you know
explicitly versus what you've
internalized
implicitly that you might not agree with
anymore you know you
things might happen in your childhood
and and they probably do
right where you you get a trauma i don't
know i i
i um i i'm afraid of dogs and and maybe
when i was a five-year-old
some dogs jumped me and i don't even
remember it right but i came to a
conclusion when i was five
dogs bad yeah dog's dangerous right and
now anytime i see a dog oh my god
that bringing my emotions aligned with
reality right with my
ideas is no now i understand dogs don't
have to be
scary i can work through this i know
various techniques and
hopefully if there is such a science of
psychology but in psychology to get you
to the point
where you can get rid of that fear and
align your emotion now
with your explicit ideas and that's what
i mean by that and let me build on that
talking about your friend putin i think
i mentioned this before at least maybe
on the show
he was meeting with angela merkel
vladimir putin yeah
my boyfriend he was mean with angela
merkel angela merkel has
a fear of dogs so he brought out his big
labrador retriever now for people who
don't know labradors are
very big dogs but they're also like the
least aggressive it's like you could
punch them in the face they don't care
that dog is not going to be more likely
to attack
just because she's scared and it's it's
kind i know they say animals can sense
your domesticated dogs
if they see you're scared they're not
going to be aggressive they're going to
try to
i remember when i was a kid i will never
there's this dog rex this german
shepherd
i'm five this jog is gigantic and i'm
sitting the couch
german shepherds have been bred for
intelligence they're very bright dogs
they're very good with kids
he's sitting next to me this thing is
three times my size
he very gently puts his paw on my leg to
be like kid like he gets that's my fear
he's like i'm not gonna do it like i
want to be your friend
i'm still freaking out he licks my hand
it's just very
scary you know animals are so bright but
that's the thing is in terms of facts
don't care about your feelings
that dog is not more likely to attack
someone
because their emotion is so intense it's
it's not that
i feel something very strongly therefore
this thing is more likely to happen so
my intensity of my emotion
does not in any way correlate in when
you're being irrational
to the likelihood of that thing actually
happening no you could have a dog that
does respond to your emotions
right but then it's but then it's not
it's that's part of reality
right that's that's a fact of reality
that certain dogs respond to certain
emotions
but isn't this emotion a part of reality
that's ex
like okay let me let me say yes so part
of that i would even say
don't let your emotion about your
emotion right because sometimes you have
an emotion about your emotions be
repressed
don't be repressed and identify the
emotion as reality
and evaluate it don't judge it evaluate
it is it a rational emotion is it
consistent with my
like if i'm afraid of these dogs if i
feel that fear
is it rational to be afraid of these
dogs but you're speaking to your own
individual trajectory as a human being
as you grow through the world and try to
understand reality and connect yourself
to reason to reali what i'm talking
about is
that term like lived experience when you
when you
observe uh and analyze
the you know conversations well with
other people to try to understand
how other people see the world doesn't
in emotion fundamentally integrate into
that
like is an emotion lived experience so
everybody experiences the same reality
but the way they experience it might be
very different and that has to do with
what does that what's their values with
their conclusions with their ideas with
their experiences with a million
different things
but is it right but at the end of the
day it's about the conclusions that they
come to which are then shaping their
emotions
but look emotions are not something to
be avoided or ignored that is
i can sense your emotions to some extent
right
okay it is
and that's part of the facts of reality
right so if if
if if michael responds to something that
i view
as really really important right if if
if we were standing in front of
michelangelo's david
michael response to michael
michelangelo's david was yeah
and turned his back to it and walked
away that would be really meaningful to
me right
that i would respond emotionally to that
and cognitively i would say
what is it about michael that makes him
you know uh
respond this way that is that is that
gives me a lot of information about him
so emotions
are information laden right but they are
not primary
they are responses responses to
something so once one must be very aware
of one's own emotions recognize them
and analyze them and one one should be
aware of other people's emotions if
they're important to you if they're not
important to you
it doesn't matter right you don't care
about a stranger's emotion yeah like a
stranger walks up to my killings those
days
and walks away and i go okay i'm glad
you're a stranger
um but it's
not now i've no idea what michael's
response to michael and jill's david was
or is so
i'm a little white about what he's going
to say you got candy too that was great
hey do i get anything i thought i was
just i don't know i can't read either
what's this thing
what does that say to him is this
ukrainian candy as well i thought
it was said to be you know that atlas
shrugged was the best-selling book in
ukraine in 2015 and 2016.
do you know shrugged was translated to
russian by someone who's not crypto like
billionaire and he made like six copies
and i have one of them and i sent it to
my great grandmother
they're more than six but yeah but they
were like okay not i personally the
institute has a copy i sent it to my
great grandma
and she said why is he sending me this i
want to read books about love and i'm
like you know what it's about love
that's what you should have said what's
that does that say so this says it's uh
it has vitamins and minerals there's a
there's a bunch of russian i don't
believe it
it's just that it just sounds like
really
it sounds really strange to read like
health information in russian there you
go exactly
already there's a
wow strong words but this is uh this
does not it's like hard candy i don't
know i think
this some of my friends sent me that's
made with blood to give the kids iron
who's blood like cow blood oh like with
chocolate
all right you can keep it that's all you
all right i'm keeping but can i can i
can i take all these something you're
talking about with the motion
something that is very pernicious in
terms of emotion is people denying the
validity of their own emotions and
here's one example
someone could be in an abusive
relationship or have had an abusive
childhood and they think well
i didn't have a black eye we had dinner
on the table it wasn't abusive because
you hear some
other story so they feel their emotion
isn't valid or like oh he never
lays hands on me he gets drunk and is
mean to me
he's still basically a good person
you're denying that emotion
and that emotion is a response to
something real there's an expression i
have friends who are in 12-step programs
there's an expression there which i
think is very profound
which is if it's hysterical it's
historical meaning if some minor
incident
is having an extreme disproportionate
impact on you
think ask yourself why am i responding
in such an extreme way
to some minor thing and i will tell you
10 times out of 10
you'll go back and you'd be like oh i'm
feeling now like i felt when i was 8
and my dad came home and he was a total
jerk and i didn't do anything wrong and
he thought i had
and i was completely powerless and now
i'm in the same situation my boss i'm
not that eight-year-old in one sense i
am another sense i'm not
but i feel the same way i did as a kid
and this is a very useful mechanism
in terms of furthering one's happiness
because you kind of deprogram
all those things that you picked up as a
child but it's also you know if you're
feeling something
wrong even though you're trying to
rationalize in a way you know it's not
abusive because he's not hitting me
no the emotion is telling you something
real about what's going on
so acknowledge it and fix the situation
right so so
one of the powers emotions give you is
they send you signals
about something that might not be in
cognition yet yeah
and when you examine their motion it
brings it to cognition yeah and now you
can act on it so maybe the boss is
abusive
but i didn't really think of it in those
terms and my emotions is
sending me signals and now that i signal
it i'm going to resign i'm going to find
a better
another job i'm going to complain to his
boss or whatever i'm going to take
action
you